hey everyone so in the last video I
introduced this thing called the second
partial derivative test and if you have
some kind of multi variable function or
really just a two variable function is
what this applies to something that's f
of X Y and it outputs a number when
you're looking for places where it has a
local maximum or a local minimum the
first step as I talked about a few
videos ago is to find where the gradient
equals 0 and sometimes you'll hear these
called critical points or stable points
but inputs where the gradient equals
zero and that's really just a way of
compactly writing the fact that all the
partial derivatives are equal to zero
now when you find a point like this in
order to test whether it's a local
maximum or a local minimum or a saddle
point without actually looking at the
graph because you don't always have the
ability to do that at your disposal the
first step is to compute this long value
and this is the thing I want to give
intuition behind where you take all
three second partial derivatives the
second partial derivative with respect
to X the second partial derivative with
respect to Y and the mixed partial
derivative where first you do it with
respect to X then you do it with respect
to Y and you compute this value where
you evaluate each one of those at your
critical point and you multiply the two
P or second partial derivatives and then
subtract off the square of the mixed
partial derivative and again I'll give
intuition for that in a reason but right
now we just kind of take it over all
right I guess you compute this number
and if that value H if that value H is
greater than zero what it tells you what
it tells you is that you definitely have
either a maximum or a minimum so you
definitely have either a maximum or a
minimum and then to determine which one
you just have to look at the concavity
in one direction so you'll look at the
second partial derivative with respect
to X for example and if that was
positive that would tell you when you
look in the X direction there's a
positive concavity if it was negative it
would mean a negative concavity and so
that means a positive value for that
second partial derivative would mean a
local minimum and a negative value would
mean a local maximum so that's that's
what it means if this value H turns out
to be greater than zero and if this
value H turns out to be less than zero
strictly less than zero then you
definitely have a saddle point saddle
point which is neither a maximum nor
minimum it's kind of like there's
disagreement in different directions
over whether it should be a maximum or
minimum
and if H equals zero the test isn't good
enough you would have to do something
else to figure it out so why does this
work why does this seemingly random
conglomeration of second partial
derivatives give you a test that lets
you determine what type of stable point
you're looking at well let's just
understand each term individually so
this second partial derivative with
respect to X since you're taking both
partial derivatives with respect to X
you're basically treating the entire
multi variable function as if X is the
only variable and Y was just some
constant so it's like you're only
looking at movement in the X direction
so in terms of a graph let's say we've
got like this graph here you can imagine
slicing this with a plane that
represents movement purely in the X
direction so that'll be a constant Y
value slice and you take a look at the
curve where this slice intersects your
graph and then the one that I have
pictured here it looks like it's a
positive concavity so so this term right
here kind of tells you X concavity so
it's kind of like the what is the
concavity as far as the variable X is
concerned and then symmetrically this
over here when you take the partial
derivative with respect to Y two times
in a row it's like you're ignoring the
fact that X is even a variable and
you're looking purely at what movement
in the Y Direction looks like which on
the graph that I have pictured here also
happens to give you kind of this
positive concavity parabola look but the
point is that the curve on the graph
that results from looking at movement
purely in the Y Direction can be
analyzed just looking at this partial
derivative with respect to Y twice in a
row so that term kind of tells you why
concavity why concavity now first of all
notice what happens if these disagree if
say X thought there should be positive
concavity and Y thought there should be
negative concavity here I'll write that
down what that means if X thinks there's
positive concavity we have here some
kind of positive number that I'll just
write as like a plus sign in parentheses
and then this here Y concavity would be
some kind of negative number so I'll
just put like a negative sign in
parenthesis so that would mean this very
first term would be a positive times a
negative and that first term would be
negative and now the thing that we're
subtracting off I'll get to the
intuition behind this mixed partial
derivative term in a moment but for now
you can notice that it's something
squared it's something that's always a
positive term
so you're always subtracting off a
positive term which means if this
initial one is negative the entire term
H is definitely going to be negative so
it's going to put you over into this
saddle point territory which makes sense
because if the X direction in the Y
direction disagree on concavity that
should be a saddle point the
quintessential example here is when you
have when you have the function f of X y
is equal to x squared minus y squared x
squared minus y squared and the graph of
that by the way the graph of that would
look like this where let's see so
orienting myself here moving in the X
direction you have kind of positive
concavity which corresponds to the
positive coefficient in front of x
squared and in the Y direction it looks
like negative concavity corresponding to
that negative coefficient in front of
the Y squared so when there's
disagreement among these the test
ensures that we're going to have a
saddle point now what about if they
agree right what if either it's the case
that X thinks there should be positive
concavity and Y thinks there should be
positive concavity or they both do agree
that there should be you know negative
concavity in either one of these cases
when you multiply them together they're
positive so it's kind of like saying if
you look purely in the X direction or
purely in the Y direction they agree
that there should be you know definitely
positive concavity or definitely
negative concavity so that entire first
term is going to be positive so it's
kind of like a clever way of capturing
whether or not the X directions and y
directions agree however the reason that
it's not enough is because in either
case we're still subtracting off
something that's always a positive term
so when you have this agreement between
the X direction and a Y direction it
then turns into a battle between this X
Y agreement and whatever's going on with
this mixed partial derivative term and
the stronger that mix partial derivative
term the bigger this negative number so
the more it's pulling the entire value H
towards being negative so let me see if
I can give a little bit of reasoning
behind why this mixed partial derivative
term is trying to pull things towards
being a saddle point let's take a look
at the very simple function f of XY XY
is equal to x times y so what that looks
like graphically f of XY equals x times
y is this
it looks like a saddle point so let's go
ahead and look at its partial
derivatives so the the first partial
derivatives partial with respect to X
and partial with respect to Y well when
you do it with respect to X X looks like
a variable Y looks like a constant it's
just that constant Y and when you do it
with respect to Y it goes the other way
around Y looks like the variable X looks
like the constant so the derivative is
that constant X now when you take the
second partial derivatives if you do it
with respect to X twice in a row you're
differentiating this with respect to X
that looks like a constant so you get
zero and similarly if you do it with
respect to Y twice in a row you're doing
this and the derivative of X with
respect to Y X looks like a constant
goes to zero but the important term the
one that we're getting an intuition
about here this mixed partial derivative
first with respect to X then with
respect to Y well we can view it in two
ways either you take the derivative of
this expression with respect to Y in
which case it's 1 or you think of taking
the derivative of this expression with
respect to X in which case it's also 1
so it's kind of like this this function
is a very pure way to take a look at
what this mixed partial derivative term
looks like and the higher the
coefficient here if I had put a
coefficient of you know 3 here that
would mean that the mixed partial
derivative would ultimately end up being
3 so notice the reason that this looks
like a saddle isn't because the X and y
directions disagree in fact if you take
a look at pure movement in the X
direction it just looks like a constant
the height of the graph along this plane
along this line here is just a constant
which corresponds to the fact that the
second partial derivative with respect
to X is equal to 0 and then likewise if
you cut it with a plane representing a
constant X value meaning movement'
purely in the Y direction the height of
the graph doesn't really change along
there it's constantly 0 which
corresponds to the fact that the souther
partial derivative is 0 the reason that
the whole thing looks like a saddle is
because when you cut it with a diagonal
plane here a diagonal plane it looks
like it has negative concavity but if
you were to chop it you know in another
direction it would look like it has
positive concavity so in fact this XY
term is kind of like a way of capturing
whether there's disagreement in the
diagonal directions
and one thing that might be surprising
at first is that you only need one of
these second partial derivatives in
order to determine all of the
information about the diagonal
directions because you could imagine you
know maybe there's disagreement between
movement along one certain vector and
movement along another and you would
have to account for infinitely many
directions and look at all of them and
yet evidently it's the case that you
only really need to take a look at this
mixed partial derivative term you know
along with the original pure second
partial derivatives with respect to X
twice and with respect to Y twice but
still looking at only three different
terms to take into account possible
disagreement in infinitely many
directions actually feels like quite the
surprise and if you want the full
rigorous justification for why this is
the case why this second partial
derivative test works in kind of an
airtight argument I've put that in an
article that you can find that kind of
goes into the dirty details for those
who are interested but if you just want
the intuition I think it's fine to think
about the fact that this mixed partial
derivative is telling you how much your
function looks like the graph of f of XY
equals x times y which is the graph that
kind of captures all of the diagonal
disagreement and then when you let that
term that mix partial derivative term
kind of compete with the agreement
between the x and y directions
you know if they agree very strongly you
have to subtract off a very strong
amount in order to pull it back to being
negative so this this battle back and
forth if it's pulled to be very negative
that will give you a saddle point if it
doesn't pull hard enough then the
agreement between the X and y directions
wins out and it's it's either a local
maximum or a local minimum so hopefully
that sheds a little bit of light on why
this term makes sense and why it's a
reasonable way to combine the three
different second partial derivatives
available to you and again if you want
the full details I've written that up in
an article form I'll see you next video